well uh the main event begins uh the
resolution again replacing the Federal
Reserve with free market institutions
would significantly improve the
economy's money Banking and Financial
systems arguing for the affirmative uh
Professor Lawrence white Lawrence please
come to the stage
arguing
arguing arguing the negative uh Columbia
University professor of banking and
financial institutions Frederick
Michigan Frederick please come to the
stage
[Applause]
um Professor white you have a 17 and a
half minutes uh maximum to make your
case uh please take it away
okay
so the resolution is that replacing the
Federal Reserve with free market
institutions would significantly improve
the economy's money Banking and
Financial systems
nothing requires that money be produced
by governments
money like a loaf of bread or like a
cell phone is what economists call a
private good
its use is rival in consumption if I'm
using some money other people can't use
it at the same time
and it's excludable the money in my bank
account is not available to other people
and so there's the
Goods that failed to meet those criteria
are sort of the standard case for
rationalizing government provision
because they make it difficult to charge
users
on a user pays basis
but money doesn't have those
characteristics so there's no prima
facie reason to expect the market to
fail to produce money
of the kind that people want to hold
and of course we still do have lots of
private money in our economy commercial
Banks issue checking accounts that's
private money
paper currency is still privately
produced in a few places in the world
and if we delve into the past even coins
have been uh privately produced
and if we delve into the future we have
cryptocurrencies
so seems to me the burden of proof ought
to be on those who want to nationalize
the provision of money
but I understand that the status quo is
what it is the supply of basic money is
controlled by governments and so the
burden in Practical terms is on me to
make a case that
the provision of money by the private
sector is not only feasible but
preferable
so that's what I want to argue that we'd
be better off if we allowed free market
alternatives to replace the Federal
Reserve System and the panoply of Bank
regulations
I'm going to focus on a particular
version of free market money I'm going
to focus on a gold standard with a free
banking system
because it has the best historical
evidence
I consider a Bitcoin standard possible
but less likely
because its purchasing power is more
volatile or would be more volatile even
if it was the monetary standard
but if you think Bitcoin is the private
sector money you support please do vote
for my side thank you
so in the kind of system I'm talking
about how would money behave uh under
the influence of Market forces
too few economists even study this
question
I took a look at Professor Michigan's uh
Market leading money and banking
textbook
doesn't discuss the topic of why we have
central banks or what the alternatives
are or whether the Alternatives would be
better the status quo and this is true
in other textbooks as well is taken for
granted and let's talk about how it
works
uh
but I'm kind of an oddball I've been
studying this issue for many years
I suppose that's why gene asked me to
take the affirmative side but it's
certainly why I accepted because I think
there's a pretty strong case
so I'm going to draw on historical
examples that I've accumulated over the
years I'm going to talk more about money
and banking than I am about Finance
as a private good money in banking have
been privately and competitively
produced through history in places where
the state hasn't completely stamped it
out
so money doesn't need a sovereign backer
or issuer to have a market value and
this is contrary to a view known as the
state theory of money or sometimes as
chartalism
there were no State insignias on the
very earliest monies on cowry shells
on
what anthropologists call hack silver
just
pieces of silver that weren't in coin
form
silver and gold coins were privately
produced and before they were
monopolized by the state and they even
when they were produced by the state
they traded by weight not by the
insignia
people learn not to trust the Insignia
of the state as certifying the coin
in the 19th century privately issued
banknotes were the most popular kind of
money
they were a bigger source of Bank
funding than deposits so more than half
of the money stock was privately issued
banknotes
and as I mentioned there have even been
privately minted coins and I'd like to
talk about those because I published a
paper last year in the economic history
review so look that up if you have
access to jstor uh about this successful
record of private gold mints uh in the
United States during the three gold
rushes
in U.S history
now it's a complicated story and there
were some private mints that did a bad
job they were either incompetently run
or they were run by scam artists
who deliberately produced underweight
coin but the important thing is that
those submits didn't survive they didn't
survive more than a few weeks once the
word got out that a mint was producing
underweight coins
nobody would bring them their gold to
coin because those coins would not be
easy to spend the word was out
so the mints that succeeded and lasted
were the ones producing high quality
coins and full weight coins
and they produced significant volumes of
coins millions of dollars worth so even
that case can be handled by the private
sector
why did governments then choose to
monopolize mints well it goes back to
ancient times
so you shouldn't expect to find a public
welfare reason for it
it wasn't to improve the quality of the
coins and in fact ancient and medieval
mints notoriously debased the coins
no it was a source of Revenue
right call in the coins re-mint them
with half as much silver in
each coin and you've made a tidy profit
for the sovereign
similar story uh applies to why
governments monopolize the issue of
paper currency not to improve its
quality not because there was any market
failure but because there was a fiscal
aspect to it a revenue Potential from it
looking into the near future people are
talking about a central bank digital
currency and I say well hold on
first make a case that the private
sector can't produce digital currency
efficiently because we have venmo so why
do we need a Fed version of venmo
one concern people have about privately
issued money uh especially if the only
thing they know about monetary history
is the U.S in the early 19th century is
that there's going to be a confusing
variety of monies trading at fluctuating
values
but that's not actually the common
experience that was the experience in
the U.S because we had laws against
Branch Banking that made it impossible
for banks to set up Redemption agencies
for their notes when they got out of the
city where they were issued they weren't
allowed to Branch across state lines
they couldn't set up Redemption offices
there was the big exception though of
the Suffolk system in New England
where a bank in Boston did arrange with
other Banks to accept their notes at par
in Boston and the system spread
throughout New England so there was an
area where money did circulate banknotes
did circulate at full face value 100
cents on the dollar
throughout the region and that's what
you find in other countries Banks set up
Branch offices there weren't any laws
against them doing that
and so their money circulated at par
throughout the country because it's in
the interest of a bank to make sure its
money circulates at par they'll get more
customers that way and you could say the
same thing is true about the the private
mints that survived
so in a freely evolved banking system
based on this historical record the
definitive money was gold or silver coin
the unit of account was so much gold so
the dollar had a definition as so many
ounces of pure silver or later so many
ounces of gold
uh the common money though was not coins
people didn't carry big bags of coins
everywhere they paid with bank issued
money banknotes as I already mentioned
and Merchants especially with checking
accounts
uh all denominated in the gold dollar
and all uh accepted widely at par
and of course the technology for deposit
transfer has advanced since the 19th
century but
there's no reason we can't have phone
transfers of gold denominated money any
more than dollar Fiat money Fiat
denominated money so you see in these
systems not in only in the U.S not only
in New England but also in Scotland and
Canada and 50 more places if you there's
an article by Kurt Schuler which has a
fairly complete list
many issuers all denominated in a common
unit widely accepted at par
all the banks are linked into a common
clearing system
so they accept one another's liabilities
checks and banknotes and then redeem
them at the Clearinghouse and that keeps
the system uh
within check but no Central Bank
competition is generally better than
Monopoly and the same is true in
currency and the same is true I think we
all take for granted in deposit banking
if somebody said we should just have one
deposit bank and it should be run by the
government it would say Well they're
going to be lousy on consumer service
uh
but the same reasons that deposit
banking should be competitive also apply
to currency
and if you want a classic account of the
argument Adam Smith book of uh Wealth of
Nations book two chapter two
he makes three main points
it's better for customers to have
competition for their business they get
better terms
if any One Bank fails or makes some kind
of money supply error
if it's only one Bank out of 20 it's not
of so much consequence then if it's the
only Bank of issue
and so that was the argument against
giving the bank of England an Ever
stronger Monopoly in the issue of money
in London
and then the Third important thing about
competition is that the banks check each
other the clearing system limits the
danger of any large-scale over issue
by
presenting the bank that over issued
with a big bunch of notes or checks to
clear and that means they lose reserves
and that's their signal that they've
over issued and it's a prompt signal
that's the important thing
so the quantity of money is limited to
the quantity the public willingly will
hold
now
competition and the discipline of the
Clearinghouse still doesn't mean that no
bank will ever fail
Adam Smith wrote about one spectacular
failure doing his day the the air Bank
Ayr but
it's almost a play on words because it
was built on very shaky foundations
but importantly its failure didn't bring
down the other major note issuing Banks
because they knew not to be indebted to
it
and so its failure didn't bring down the
entire system the system not only
quickly recovered
but actually got stronger so in
Naseem taleb's terminology it wasn't a
fragile banking system it was an
anti-fragile banking system other
Bankers took lessons from what the air
bank had done wrong and stopped doing
those kinds of things
so what you want in a banking system is
anti-fragility and what do you need for
that you need a healthy variety not
every Bank doing the same thing so that
they can all end up doing the wrong
thing
it's one of the problems with today's
regulatory system that we've fostered on
what you might call a monoculture of
banking all the large Banks pretty much
behave the same way because their
Regulators asked them to
so why do we have central banks
uh let me quote what Alan Greenspan once
told Jon Stewart quote you don't need a
central bank when we were on the gold
standard which was back in the 19th
century
and all the automatic things occurred
because people would buy and sell gold
and the market would do what the FED
does now
by which he meant the money supply would
adjust to the demand for money
so the money supply is self-regulating
under a gold standard and of course the
U.S was on the gold standard when the
Federal Reserve Act was passed so here's
Alan Greenspan saying the U.S got a
central bank that it didn't need
and the main impetus for the Federal
Reserve Act
was that there were Financial panics a
series of financial panics
but they weren't inherent in competition
and decentralization or even in being on
the gold standard and we know that
because our neighbor to the north Canada
had Free banking a more free banking
than the U.S it had Banks issuing the
currency
it had a gold standard it had an
agricultural economy like the U.S it had
no panics
so we need to find a difference between
the U.S and Canada to explain the
difference in the fragility of the
financial system
and it's not hard to find there were
legal restrictions on U.S banks that
Canadian Banks didn't have namely the
Restriction of branching that I've
already mentioned
but also there was a requirement that
U.S banks couldn't issue more currency
unless they had more collateral in the
form of federal debt and this scheme was
started during the Civil War to Market
Union government debt
uh but it sort of outlived its
usefulness and became an important
constraint
so that when there was a seasonal demand
for currency the banks couldn't meet it
and that meant the banks lost reserves
and that's why they were Financial
panics a lot of people at the time saw
this and said we ought to be more like
Canada we ought to deregulate our way
back to stability
but the small Bank lobby didn't want
large Banks branching into their
neighborhoods and so politically uh
it didn't succeed and of course small
Banks blocked a lot of Reform we didn't
get Interstate Branch Banking in the U.S
Nationwide until the 1990s
so
um
that's banking monetary policy the fed
and other central banks actually the
fed's not the worst of central banks but
the track record of monetary policy is
not very good it's pretty poor
if you compare Fiat monies since 1971
that's when the Bretton Woods system
ended and we got Pure Fiat money
we've had higher inflation than we had
under the classical gold standard
we've had a less predictable price level
and you see that in the shrinkage of the
market for 30 and 50-year bonds they
become very rare because nobody knows
what a dollar is going to be worth
30 years from now whereas under the gold
standard you got a pretty good idea what
the dollar is going to be worth 30 years
from now
it's often thought that okay we've got
more inflation but at least we've
conquered the business cycle no I got
bad news for you we haven't conquered
the business cycle
uh in an article with two co-authors we
measured the variance of real output in
the U.S since 1971 and it's no lower
output is no steadier
today than it was during the period of
the classical gold standard
so uh I think a gold standard with Free
banking I think there's evidence would
be better than the status quo it would
give us more stability of purchasing
power
it would give us a Sounder banking
system
we wouldn't need too big to fail
we wouldn't need the moral hazard that
comes with that and it would give us
Sounder Finance if we didn't have a
central bank to issue
things like the Greenspan put which sort
of opened the door to moral hazard in
other Financial intermediaries
how can we get there
hopefully by not by hyperinflation which
is how some countries have lost their
Fiat monies nobody hopes for that
but by reform and I don't think it's
going to happen tomorrow I understand
that there's a long case of Education to
be made
uh but when we're ready for it
we'll be ready for uh Free banking on a
gold standard thank you
speak speaking for the America of
federal commission take it away
Frederick
so I feel a little bit like uh Daniel
going to the Lion's Den because I know
the Soho forum is a Libertarian
organization
so I'd like you know one thing that was
said earlier is actually the need for
debate is so important nowadays uh we're
both in universities and uh uh my
University I don't know what George
Mason is like but there really a lot of
topics that are extremely difficult to
discuss uh in a rational way uh it's
very depressing sometimes uh because of
my age I actually uh teach for example
about culture and economics none of my
junior colleagues will do so because
they realize it could cause them a lot
of problems and for me if it doesn't
work out I just retire so it's not a big
deal
uh so what I'd like to do first because
I'd like you to think about this was
part of the debate is I'd like to
actually make some general comments
about libertarianism okay so I have read
uh Atlas Shrugged I've read Fountainhead
I love the books fantastic books I
enjoyed them thoroughly uh but let me
give you a perspective on where I stand
so if we take a scale of one to ten uh
and uh one is progressives Like Bernie
Sanders let's put them at that end uh
and uh 10 would be uh uh the two poles
Ron and Rand Paul uh building Friedman I
put probably about maybe eight and a
half nine kind of thing I'd be about a
seven so I am somebody who's very Pro
markets uh and the issue that that is
critical however is that markets uh only
work well if they have the right
governance and certain characteristics
so markets in general are better uh but
on the other hand there can be problems
and there are actually three kind of
problems that you face in markets which
where they don't do the job very well
one is where they may not have been able
to have enough competition so you can
get monopolies developing uh where in
fact it's there's no competition and and
one of the things that that you
mentioned which I really strongly agree
with the key to getting an economy
that's successful and actually getting
life to be successful is competition
actually one of the things that that
people don't realize about universities
is that we actually are very dog eat dog
we are always competing with others in
American universities in terms of making
our place more prestigious uh and that's
one of the reasons why U.S universities
dominate the world in terms of uh in
terms of uh people wanting to come come
to universities and I actually really uh
like that so one is that you want a a
market that actually will become
competitive the second reason markets
can have problems if in fact information
is not there we would call this
asymmetric information in economics
different parties have different
information things can really get screwy
uh uh uh screwy in that and that in that
case as well so uh what you think about
this is you ask yourselves and then the
third is what we call externalities the
fact that that you can do something that
actually harms somebody else
and actually is uh you're not able to
get to compensate that person for it uh
by the way they can be positive
externalities we usually worry about
markets when they're negative aware
positive externalities like for example
research development is where you do
something you and in fact it helps
everybody else and you don't get paid
for it so those three things mean that
markets sometimes don't work very well
and the key is getting the right
institutions behind markets to get them
to to work very well and and in fact
this is something that I teach and talk
a lot about uh in my courses where I
actually say uh from if you remember the
Gordon Gecko and Wall Street said greed
is good
well agreed in fact generally is good if
the markets are are set up the right way
but greed can also be bad and so that's
I think a very important uh uh point and
there's a wonderful book by two uh
University Chicago economists not
exactly uh uh on on the Progressive side
to say the least uh Luigi singalas and
Raghu Rajan they have a wonderful title
of the book it's called saving
capitalism from the capitalists and what
they do is they go into what what
problems that mean that markets
frequently in developing countries have
bad institutions behind them and things
things as a result don't work out very
well and there's a classic example of
this by the way which is what happened
with the end of the Soviet Union so the
Soviet Union breaks up uh communism is
gone and in fact there's a push
particularly by Western powers to say oh
we need to privatize and use markets to
make things better
well what happened was yes we privatized
yes there were markets but in fact what
happened was that we got better and more
capable monopolists taking over these
markets and it made things much much
worse
and that's actually what's going on
right now in fact the war of Ukraine
versus Russia is going to be one of the
most important events uh in history I
think because this is a battle not just
about territory and you know whether
Ukraine or Russians or whatever and
aggression this is a battle of ideas
whether Ukraine which has moved from
being very much like the Soviet Union or
like Russia and is trying to move
towards the west and I recommend very
highly to you to watch the first season
of servant of the people uh which is the
lensky show which talks about all these
the the trying to change it's very funny
uh uh and how they're trying to move
from this corrupt uh the military is
just like the Russian military how to
move it from there to something that's
much better
so let me actually now get to the issue
so I hope that stimulates some of your
thinking about libertarianism because I
know where the group that I'm coming
luckily when you do these uh who wins
the debate I got a shot because you had
to vote first and then then you had to
vote again
uh so the question is should we replace
the the fed by free markets that's
really the the issue and in fact there
were many things that I actually agree
with uh that that uh uh uh that you've
said in this context that uh that Larry
has said in this context uh he talked
about competition he also talked about
the fact that that money can be private
it doesn't have to be done by government
I agree completely with those issues uh
the real issue as I'm going to argue is
will the economy perform better with the
fed or without a Fed
that's really the issue and so I want to
talk about uh uh that and when you think
about uh how you set up a system where
you don't have a central bank you have
to tie money to something
so in fact uh Larry talked a lot about
the gold standard I think it was good
that he said a lot of people are talking
about crypto Libertarians frequently
love crypto uh the best thing about
crypto was the Larry David commercial
during the Super Bowl that to me was but
crypto is is really not something that
would be suitable it actually is
designed to be very much like gold it
has to be mined so that in fact it's
something that restrains the the total
production of it uh with real factors in
this case using up a lot of electricity
in servers uh but but clearly crypto has
such wild fluctuations in value uh
relative to other prices that if you
actually tie to crypto you'd get
incredible fluctuations in the price
level which would be very very damaging
and then of course there are all the
issues about is Christo really secure is
it safe the brokerages I think after FTX
the crypto boom in that regard is over
so I think the issue is we really do
want to talk about the gold standard
because I think that is a is a case of
where uh uh uh we did have a private uh
money type system and it actually
functioned it was there's no question
that it could function
so he here's I think the the the
good news and the bad news about a
commodity standard like the gold
standard or if you do silver or whatever
what what is the good news the good news
is that if you take very long Horizons
and Larry mentioned 30 years uh that in
fact you do get a stable price level so
for example if you look at the price
level uh when the American revolution
occurred and then look 100 years later
it's very similar so you don't tend to
get these these uh these big trends uh
which we've had in terms of actually a
price level which inflated very much
over time so that's the good news
the bad news is as John Maynard Kane
says in the long run World dead
that's not the Horizon that in fact uh
most people are functioning and they're
functioning a much shorter Horizons what
they really care about is what are the
prices going to be next year even
sometimes next three months but what are
prices going to be like in the next year
when you actually look at the data and
in fact there's a very well-known paper
by Anna Schwartz who you know is uh you
know I don't know what where we put on
the scale but she's up there with Milton
Friedman and Anna by the way who's a
wonderful scholar wonderful person we
all miss her by the way one of the
feistiest people you've ever met I would
go to conferences with her somebody say
something and she would just rip them
apart which was fantastic I loved her
and she was also a nice Jewish
grandmother too which is again A Plus
from my perspective uh but but she wrote
uh this paper and and looked at actually
the performance during the gold standard
and what you see is and it's not
surprising uh that because gold is
produced and you can have uh discoveries
uh and so forth all of a sudden the
demand for gold changes because it can
be used more for certain purposes that
what you find is that in fact the price
level had much more fluctuations under
the gold standards when you take the
shorter Horizon but I think that's
what's relevant in terms of thinking
about how the world uh works the second
issue is that when you look in the U.S
and in fact I do think that Larry's
right that there were issues of design
of the system uh that you did have a a
financial crisis and financial panics
that were very very frequent
uh and in fact uh I'm going to argue
that if a Fed knows what it's doing if
the Central Bank knows what it's doing
uh it improves tremendously on that but
it it sometimes doesn't know what it's
doing so the classic example of this and
uh is the Great Depression where the Fed
was a new organization uh because of
internal politics it's really fun if a
lot of time I tell you about all you
know uh if you if you uh one of the
things you learn when you manage people
if you basically tell people what to do
frequently they act like teenagers who
does do the opposite those kind of
tensions occurred in the Federal Reserve
System and as a result when we started
to get the first set of banking failures
uh uh towards the end of 1930 in the
fall of 1930 the FED absolutely did not
it was like Nero fiddling while Rome
burned it was a disaster
now you might say well that can keep on
happening but uh but we learned the
lessons in fact there's a wonderful
speech that Ben Bernanke gave he was a
governor at the time of the Federal
Reserve he was not uh the chair uh and
it was Milton Friedman's 90th birthday
and uh and Ben gave a speech where he
talked about this this very famous uh uh
brilliant fantastic worker which I
recommend highly to you it's it's fun it
even has a little sex drugs and rock and
roll in it too but it's scholarly about
what was going on during during the
Great Depression uh but uh but Ben said
I said Milton you know it's your 90th
birthday you're a great man he said uh
about the fed you were absolutely right
they screwed up but we've learned how
not to do that again and it's not going
to happen and then we had Ben Bernanke
who was the chair of the FED uh and of
course I was there uh with him as a
governor uh and as a result we did not
have a a disaster with the global
financial crisis so I'd like you to
think about uh what might happen or what
world might look like if we didn't have
a central bank to basically do lender of
last stop Resort operations they did it
by the way in 1987 under Greenspan very
very important it's not a well-known
example but in fact there was a
potential for everything to fall apart
when the stock market fell by 20 uh uh
in one day uh that the FED then actually
took steps very controversial uh there
were a lot of mistakes made by the way
the FED took 16 months really to get the
plan implemented properly uh when I was
a governor I was actually a 1.1 in
descent because I felt that we were not
doing our job properly that we're
getting behind the curve but nonetheless
uh the Fed was able to stop a depression
from occurring and we got close Closer
Than People realized it was the scariest
a time that that uh that uh I've ever
experienced as an economist
but let's look at but in that case you
might say well this is because of of all
the incentives from regulation the moral
hazard that Larry mentioned that's why
this happened but let's take a look at
covid so the coveted pandemic is really
a classic Act of God okay that uh
anybody says You can predict it yeah we
might do the pandemics I've just
finished watching this terrible series
that I really loved called The Last Ship
about it was done in like 2000s
10 or something like that and it's all
about a world pandemic we've talked
about that but really this was a pure
Act of God uh and uh and in fact if you
look at uh the uh uh understand
Financial crises and let me tap my own
work I've done a lot of work on
financial crisis my textbook talks about
this a lot there's there's a way of
understanding the Dynamics of financial
crises you look at what happened with
with the covet pandemic and it looked
like boy could have it sent us into a
financial crisis into depression
it actually had much less impact than
than uh than um uh than the GFC of the
global financial crisis in fact the
reason was and we got very lucky because
if covet had happened before the global
financial crisis I think we would have
had a disaster
because what happened during the global
the covet pandemic was that within uh
two weeks of announcing the pandemic
and that was pretty quick it wasn't just
that we thought about it I remember uh I
was ready to go on a trip and didn't
think anything of it and then five days
later uh the who declared a pandemic
that the FED basically did in two weeks
but it took them 16 months to do and
that's because there's learning by doing
they they learned how to handle it in
fact I'm even going to give credit to
our politicians because
I don't want to start talking about this
I'll get it my head will start to blow
off uh the partisanship is so awful
right now but in a partisan World they
actually passed a legislation to pump a
lot of money into the economy when it
was needed it was extraordinary that it
was done as fast as it was even though
they still all hate each other's guts so
uh so it was really an extraordinary
period uh that thinking about what the
world would have been like if in fact we
didn't have a Federal Reserve uh uh when
the coveted pandemic hit is just uh is
just absolutely incredibly incredibly
scary so let me conclude by saying that
uh the bottom line is I think that one
of the worst ideas now I'm not thinking
that libertarianism in general because I
think there are a lot of points about
libertarianism that you can see that I
think are are appropriate the reason why
I think that that uh that uh people are
attracted libertarianism is that people
who think that that the government
should do everything progressives
I have a colleague Joe stieglitz he did
this wonderful research on why markets
fail
he never ever worries about the fact
that governments fail
and that's really important and that's
why I end up being pretty pro-market
because even if there's a market failure
you have to ask yourself if we put in
this regulation what is it going to make
it better
and sometimes it doesn't and we've all
had to deal with this kind of issues of
crazy regulation
um actually was the Commodore of a boat
club that appear that a barge came down
from the Mario Cuomo Bridge destroyed
our pier and we could can't rebuild it
because we have well finally we might
because we had a nightmare bureaucrat
who from the Department of the New York
Department of Environmental Conservation
who reminded me of the bureaucrat in
Ghostbusters the first one remember that
bureaucrat let's all the ghosts out so
we really have to take that balance and
I think that's why we need to debate uh
to bait these issues but to be very
Frank I think the idea that we would
want to abolish central banks and to
replace them with something like an old
standard and free markets I have to tell
you I think it's one of the worst ideas
possible it would be a scary world thank
God my view is that that's not going to
happen
[Applause]
seven and a half minutes for rebuttal uh
take it away Larry
uh thank you for those remarks uh
Professor Michigan's main argument uh
against the
resolution
is that we need a central bank we need
the Federal Reserve to
ensure economic and financial stability
and let me re-emphasize something I said
earlier in the in the study I did with
the George seljin and Bill of straps
that was in the Journal of
macroeconomics in 2012.
we found that uh real stability in the
economy hasn't been any greater under
the Federal Reserve even if we confine
ourselves to post 1971.
true they screwed up in the Great
Depression and so if you add that in
then the fed's track record is even
worse than the classical gold standard
in terms of output stability but even if
you say we're not going to count that
the the it was just practice
Fed was still learning
even if you just take a more recent
period
the track record at stabilizing output
is not greater okay well let's focus on
financial stability in particular
it's often thought that the FED is
necessary to supervise and regulate
Banks
and to serve as a banker's Bank
but those were all functions that were
performed by Commercial Bank
Clearinghouse associations
and they had better incentives to get
the regulations right that is banks that
were member of the Clearinghouse wanted
assurance that the other Banks whose
liabilities they were accepting were not
going to default at the end of the day
so they wanted the other Banks to be
solvent
and they wanted some assurance that they
were solving so clearinghouses demanded
minimum Capital they demanded to see the
balance sheet and they actually demanded
to audit the balance sheets of their
member banks so an appropriate amount of
uh that kind of Regulation is undertaken
in the private sector
the clearinghouses of course wouldn't
impose uh regulations that were
against the interests of the banks or
against the interests of consumers
unless they could organize a cartel but
there's no evidence that they were
successful in doing that
uh
it's often thought that the FED is
needed to backstop the financial system
in the event of bad
happenings uh
panics
natural disasters pandemics
that without somebody there to uh
make the printing press go Burr
that there's going to be a lack of
confidence
that everybody can get their money when
they want it
uh
but in practice a banking system without
a central bank actually provides better
incentives for banks to act with more
restraint to act with more Prudence
that's an absence of moral hazard I
referred to the moral hazard problem
earlier and it's not just from too big
to fail it's from
encouraging Banks not to be adequately
liquid
probably the the biggest piece of
evidence I can offer in this regard is
that the Canadian banking system which
had no Central Bank
which had no deposit Insurance weathered
to Great Depression without a single
bank failure
the economy went down sure I mean the
economy suffered because the U.S is
their biggest trading partner so they
could hardly have not had a depression
in output but they had no financial
trouble they didn't have any bank
failures or we can compare the Scottish
banking system during the Heyday the
Free banking period to what was
happening in England where the bank of
England
was well people were encouraging it to
act as a lender of Last Resort I guess I
should admit they didn't actually do
very much last resort Lending
but in a competitive system if One bank
over expands the other banks will
discipline it by draining it of Reserves
and that helps ensure stability of each
Bank stability of the banking system
and actually stability of overall
spending in the economy
the problem with a lender of Last Resort
again is a moral hazard problem and if
in a sense it underprices the assurance
that it's giving and thereby creates
an incentive in Banks to take on bigger
risks than they would if they were
bearing all the costs themselves
let me finish with a since I quoted Alan
Greenspan earlier with a quote from Paul
volcker so after he had served as
chairman of the FED Paul volcker was
invited back to the Federal Reserve of
Kansas City's annual conference in
Jackson Hole Wyoming
Jackson Hole Wyoming is a pretty
expensive place I wonder how they afford
it
but here's what volcker said
quote
this was on a panel on the role of the
Central Bank he says quote if you say a
central bank is essential to a market
economy
I have to ask you about Hong Kong
which has no Central Bank
at all
and is the absolute epitome of a free
market economy
yet it does quite well in terms of
economic growth and stability
and I think Hong Kong is not an outlier
here if you look more broadly at the
history of banking systems you'll find
that the ones that were least restricted
uh exhibit greater stability because on
net Bank regulation has been a source
more of a source of instability than of
stability thank you
[Applause]
700 minutes of rebuttal from uh
Professor Michigan take it away
so let me talk about several issues here
uh
so first of all let's talk about this
issue about how well the FED has done
since 1971 and I think it's clear that
there are the great inflation was also a
very very bad period of monetary policy
so here's something I'm actually going
to be very I'm going to be patting
myself on the back and Academia on the
back on this the really one of the
issues is whether it's the technology of
Central Banking can get better or not
and and indeed there was a huge change
in terms of of uh of research in
macroeconomics it's called the rational
expectations Revolution uh uh Bob Lucas
one of the uh the really uh important
players uh in this regard at the
University of Chicago uh and one of the
things that that uh that we learned is
we learned the importance of actually of
credibility
and the normal anchor so you actually
have to have a nominal anchor and you
could use the gold as a normal anchor by
the way uh that's that's a possibility
but in fact what people started to
understand was that in fact if you have
a strong normal anchor something like an
inflation Target that uh that you can
actually get much much better
performance and in fact that was exactly
what eventually was adopted it took a
long time that uh there were shades of
it there was inflation targeting light
uh that uh uh when I was at the uh at
the Federal Reserve board uh I was
pushing for this quite hard internally
but couldn't talk about it till I was
ready to leave uh and I left in 2008 and
then it was it was it only took another
four years before the FED implemented
even though it was really pretty obvious
that they had to go in that direction uh
and in that sense we've actually had a
much better monetary policy indeed uh uh
we talk about this period in economics
profession talks about is the great
moderation uh it was interfered with by
the global financial crisis and that's a
separate issue of these these tremendous
shocks that really have a non-monetary
elements but can create huge problems so
one of the questions is yes the FED did
make mistakes in the past
but the other hand uh that uh science
has helped there's something called the
science of monetary policies a little
arrogant because there's no such thing
as economic science like there is in
biology where there is in something like
physics or whatever but we've really
come a long way and I think that's
really uh very important uh in terms of
uh of thinking about this uh the other
issue is to talk about these issues of
Regulation which I think are very uh
important and I do agree with Larry that
uh that the Clearinghouse associations
actually did have better incentives uh
frequently than than government and
that's one of the reasons we actually uh
uh like markets because we think
frequently that that the the pursuit of
private uh uh profits or whatever uh can
uh can actually produce more efficiency
and uh and better incentives and I think
actually he's right that uh that uh I
should tell you that all my years
spending the FED I spent five years in
FMC meetings three when I was an
Executive Vice President the Federal
Reserve back in New York and then two
when I got to actually sit at the table
when I was a governor although I never
ever felt that politics influenced a
monetary policy I can't say that about
regulation
and so the government uh and it's sort
of obvious why because monetary policy
affects everybody very broadly
regulation affects particular
institutions and boy do they Lobby like
crazy and uh and it's amazing what some
of these guys can get away with it I'm
still mad at Christian Cinema because
the carried interest is is an
Abomination it's outrage if you don't
know what this is it's basically that
you allow that yeah that you allow uh uh
private Equity firms to charge fees and
then declare that they're capital gains
and pay half the taxes this is just and
yet
she blocked it single-handedly well you
know I don't know this is true but
somebody lobbied or you know gave a few
shekels here something happened so uh uh
uh so we we know that this can be an
issue there's one really huge problem so
I would actually uh uh uh agree with
Larry that I think actually that uh
Clearing Houses because the banks
themselves they do regulate by the way
there's a lot of regulation in the
Clearinghouse associations that was done
uh not now because they don't have to do
it but they did a lot of Regulation uh
their incentives were better the big
problem is that they can't create money
out of liquidity out of thin air they
don't have this ability to do the lender
of Last Resort that's the real real uh
issue so I don't agree with him on the I
don't disagree with him on the view of
incentives but the bottom line is that
uh they just don't have the Machinery to
solve a problem when a big enough shock
hit small shocks by the way they do do a
fairly good job the big shocks are what
we're really worried about and by the
way that's why the Federal Reserve was
created because remember that there was
a banking panic in 1907 it's one of the
huge panics and we had a depression as a
result they had a national banking
commission uh the person who helped bail
out the system was JP Morgan
he had a zillion dollars
but he didn't have the multi-zillion
dollars he needed to create basically an
infinite liquidity and so that's the
problem that I have the last thing I
want to say is referring to the Hong
Kong monetary Authority uh uh he's
absolutely right that Hong Kong does not
have a monetary Authority doesn't do
monetary policy all it does is it does
do some regulatory stuff uh that they do
not have a Central Bank of the type that
other countries have
the reason they can do that is they're a
small entity they basically tie their
currency the Hong Kong whatever it's
called Hong Kong dollar yeah that's why
I'm having trouble
the Hong Kong dollar to the US dollar uh
and uh uh and that would be great if
you're a small country you do not need
to have a central bank and you could
have arguments why you might not need to
have a central bank so I have no problem
with with that the problem is that we
are the big gorilla in the room
in fact at whatever the U.S does affects
everybody else in the world we're seeing
it right now uh the fed by the way made
some very serious mistakes I I don't
know if you I'm on CNBC every time
there's a there's an fomc meeting that's
since April of of
2021 I've been saying the FED it has a
flawed policy framework they're going to
get in trouble I then had a an op-ed in
the financial time saying that they they
really have their head up their took us
to be a little bit of a New York term uh
and uh uh but I will say the following
it it it it was it's not been a disaster
didn't leave disaster led to a very
difficult situation what the FED has
done though is they actually got it in
terms of uh understanding that they had
to commit to keep inflation stable and
inflation Target and they turn the super
usually they're very slow to turn the
tank the Super Tank around now it was a
power boat
so again I think this is again some of
the learning because of the of the the
literature which you know as I say I
have been a contributor to it on
rational expectations and how to think
about monetary policy uh that uh the
technology actually has worked are we
going to have suffer a little bit
because the FED screwed up absolutely
but not all that much that doesn't mean
we have a recession some bad things but
I'm talking not that bad so in
conclusion I just uh I again I just have
to strongly disagree uh with with Larry
on this
[Applause]
um yeah
um uh thank you thanks to you both we
now come to the Q a portion of the
evening there is a microphone over there
uh so line up and ask questions and up
at the balcony uh I'll recognize people
who want to ask questions up there as
well in terms of the Q a uh you both
have uh the option of asking each other
a question at any time you can waive
that see what questions there are from
the audience uh I uh uh either of you
want to ask each other a question at
this moment uh looks like not I want to
take Monterey's prerogative to ask
Professor mishkin a question sort of the
inevitable uh sort of uh thing your
remarks would provoke
two parts really that that relate to
each other to what extent do you think
that the FED causes instability causes
business cycles and in related way uh uh
to what extent do you feel that the
Great Recession of 0809 uh which uh
brought an end to the great moderation
after all this wonderful knowledge the
FED is learning we've got the worst
downturn since the great uh depression
and then at which uh bran Bernanke did
not anticipate in which uh Anna Schwartz
didn't either and uh to what extent did
that was that caused by the fed and to
what extent does it mean that we should
lose confidence in all this learning the
FED acquires and then most recently the
inflation that's occurred where we don't
know where that's going which the FED
also seemed to deny was a problem until
of course about a year ago so could you
address those challenges
and there's been a whole lot of debate
about this issue about uh
yeah yeah you're okay going yes okay so
there's been a lot of debate about this
in fact John Taylor uh a very well-known
Economist at the uh uh at Stanford
yes please start okay sorry about that
yeah
because this one
I'm gonna give you a little tune you're
pivoting here you pivot a lot go ahead
just keep keep
you're you're a great performer but keep
the mic up with the pit okay yeah
no Okay so
so uh there was a big debate actually uh
where uh John Taylor uh basically
accused the FED uh said uh the FED
helped create the housing bubble by the
extremely easy monetary policy
so
I've been a student of financial crises
uh uh in fact the reason I became an
economist particularly a macroeconomist
is because my father who fought in World
War II
uh uh didn't talk about a lot always
told me stories about the Great
Depression and how terrible it was and
so uh I became an economist because I
really wanted to understand how to
prevent depressions
and in fact the research that that uh
started actually with Ben Bernanke won a
Nobel Prize for This research that was
the famous 1983 paper which is why he
won the Nobel Prize uh actually pointed
out that uh that it was an asymmetric
information problem uh so this
literature that actually developed in
the 1970s understanding the problems of
having different parties not having the
same information how uh how in fact this
actually was the primary cause of the
Great Depression and in fact I'm going
to plug my textbook if you read my
textbook there's a whole chapter on
financial crises and talks about what
generates Financial crises and when you
look at it it the issue of fed monetary
policy would be very easy before uh the
uh the global financial crisis that that
that's not the main story of financial
crisis you can actually go through and
understand why they develop and so forth
regulation actually is much more
important lacks regulation but that
monetary policy actually can add a
little fuel to the fire but is a minor
part of the picture
uh and so when you actually study
financial crisis understand why they
develop and so forth and financial
crisis by the way are part of sometimes
something that's good that's happening
which is that you get financial
Innovation uh and the financial
Innovation Unfortunately they don't
quite get it right so this is the South
the invention of the modern Corporation
extremely important in terms of economic
growth we had the south sea bubble uh
that uh that uh the financial Innovation
is not quite gotten right and then it
blows up on you and so that's really the
story behind what happened during the
the global financial crisis when we talk
about the recent episode where I've been
very critical uh of the FED uh there's a
question of degree did they screw up
yeah they really screwed up uh they they
had a extremely flawed policy framework
if somebody wants to ask questions I can
go into exactly how they they just uh uh
really had a bad policy framework which
deviated from what we had learned before
uh and then also some some bad
forecasting and then a little bit of bad
luck so it was all combination Ukraine
is not the fed's fault
uh however they have turned it around
now do I think this has been costly
absolutely uh is are we gonna have a
recession I think it's extremely likely
uh uh we can talk about why I think the
idea that we're going to get a soft
Landing is is you know
if you get Super Lucky maybe but boy you
got to be really lucky so it's I don't
think that's gonna happen uh but again
this is not going to be a disaster so
yes we're going to have a period where
inflation's too high absolutely it's
it's coming down uh is the Fed fed gonna
have to have very tight monetary policy
which is going to hurt the economy
absolutely uh but this is not a disaster
and in fact when shocks hit the economy
business Cycles are going to be be
around so one point people saying oh
great moderation we're never going to
have business Cycles again no it's like
death and taxes it's always going to be
around
okay uh would you like to comment on the
question Larry about the Great Recession
and the recent inflation yeah
yeah so I I agree uh every time you said
the FED screwed up I agree with all that
uh the question is can we rely on
central banks to continuously improve
over time and I don't see a lot of
evidence that we can so as Gene said the
great moderation came to an end
um and you mentioned John Taylor and
Taylor has pointed out that
compared to what it had been doing
during the Great moderation the FED
started after the.com bubble
the FED kept interest rates too low for
too long and thereby fueled
maybe not the only cause but fueled the
housing bubble
and then more recently we've had you
know nine percent inflation
uh
which shocked even me shocked me too uh
I I thought when it got to five percent
they would put their foot on the brakes
but it took a little longer than that
before they really started to take it
seriously so
some of the things I thought the FED had
learned they don't seem to have learned
in a very robust way
and you know Central Banking policy is
subject to not just continuous
Improvement in technology but fads and
Fashions and sound ideas go out of style
so
it's not a reliable system
so I I agree with you that the issue
that assuming that the central bank is
always going to get it right is
incorrect and we see they make mistakes
they get group think uh this was
actually uh uh I talked to Jay about
this kind of stuff they just had a a
group thing that that occurred which was
was hugely problematic and the mistake
they had this team transitory stuff that
all these shocks would be uh transitory
there were a lot of people in the
markets who thought that too I thought
that that uh the problem is that they
didn't talk about the demand shock which
were huge uh because of uh of what a
consider very bad piece of legislation
which is American Recovery Act it was
just way too large uh and was not a
Recovery Act at all it was it was at
least double what was needed uh in that
context or is the inflation reduction
act oh the inflation reduction yeah well
that's not even called the inflation
reduction act because it has nothing to
do with inflation reduction and so it's
gonna
[Applause]
so let me make a dig that this like
modern monetary Theory and it's the it
and when I was a kid you probably I'm
old but there was a joke that you may
remember which was the Holy Roman Empire
it wasn't holy it wasn't Roman it wasn't
an Empire
and modern monetary Theory isn't modern
it's not monetary and it's not a theory
so so you guys are starting to agree
with each other too much we're losing
the debate here we're losing the The
Edge the issue here is uh uh the
question is when you make a mistake
you're not going to get a perfect it's a
tough business of doing forecasting by
the way I've been in there uh the issue
is going to be what the alternative is
and as I've argued that uh that uh these
Alternatives of tying to something that
has some real aspects to it like gold
gold or crypto whatever
is not going to produce the kind of of
of uh of uh stability that people like
it was people think of golden age there
were some very good things about the
gold standard by the way in terms of
promoting globalization but that's a
whole topic that we don't want to
discuss because that's not the subject
of the debate okay uh okay question
please ask a question here's a question
go ahead yes
question for Larry uh just wondering
what's special about tying a free
banking system to the gold standard as
opposed to two metals like gold and
silver or for that matter just having a
free banking system based on multiple
competing Fiat currencies
yeah that's a good question
um
I've studied bimedalism and there's a
better case for bimedalism that Milton
Friedman discusses that is better than
the case that uh William Jennings Bryan
made for it
but still uh the problem that
bi-medicalism tried to solve was have
both gold and silver
full-bodied coins in circulation
simultaneously
but it's a rear guard action you don't
need to do that once you have Bank
issued money
you can have all the small change you
want in the form of Hank ious banknotes
and token coins you don't need to have
full-bodied coins
now if you can trust the bankers so
people didn't trust the government they
wanted government coins to be
full-bodied silver and I understand that
but if you can trust the issuer of the
tokens you don't need two metals now on
the the general point is quite right it
there's nothing
unique about gold except for its history
all right so I use gold as an example
because we have some evidence on its
Behavior but a silver standard would
behave pretty much the same way
uh other commodities
I don't know but one of the nice things
about a gold or silver standard
is that it has this self-correcting
tendency built into it that if there's
an increase in demand for money and it
starts to raise the purchasing power of
money
it'll stimulate more Supply gold miners
will dig a Little Deeper more
Prospectors will go out there'll be more
research and development on how to
produce high-grade cold out of low-grade
ore that sort of thing so it is a long
run tendency I I grant that it's not a
year to year thing
but actually some of the views economic
historians have had about how much
volatility there was in the purchasing
power of gold from year to year
are based on faulty statistics where in
the 19th century the price indexes are
reconstructed from just a few commodity
series that we have they're not as
broad-based if you correct for that it
doesn't look so volatile it's because
we've only got an index with you know a
dozen or two dozen Commodities but in
principle it could be something else if
everybody converged on something else
we know historically they converged on
Silver and Gold
I think it's plausible that the economy
would again
given this long-run stabilization
property that's built into them
coming from you Frederick or you want to
pass coming no
Mike Mike yeah Mr President not a debate
I always thought there was an issue
though that could be a problem if you
have bimetallic that if there's a big
Supply change in one versus the other
that it does create problems and I
that's right that's why I actually agree
that that if you're going to do it
probably it's a little bit better to do
Vic one commodity just because of this
issue I don't know if you agree with
that so I agree with bate but I think
it's interesting we've got agreement
okay uh next question
uh question yes into the mic please yes
my question is for both of you can you
and can each of you in layman's terms
define inflation versus deflation
as simply as possible please oh
Frederick why don't you take it so this
is what I do my textbook so hopefully
I'm going to get it right so uh uh
inflation is an increase in the price
level what do we mean by the price level
it's the average level of prices and now
there's a little tricky issues whether
you use the CPI the PC deflator because
there's different weights on uh
different different Goods so inflation
is when the average level of prices is
going up and deflation is when the
average level of prices is going down
coming Larry yeah I'm not sure whether
this motivates your question but a
hundred years ago it was different the
term inflation was used to describe what
today we call monetary expansion that is
an increase in the supply of money
rather than the result which is the
rising price level
but I've given up that debate I mean
what's the point we have a perfectly
good term for monetary expansion it's
monetary expansion
uh next question uh please uh read again
I'm afraid excuse me I'm sorry only one
question at a time
deflation is just a decrease so the
average prices are all going down that's
a deflation
yes okay uh next question
um crypto is kind of uh dismissed but it
still has more than a trillion dollar
market cap the price of Bitcoin is
actually higher now than it was before
FTX and it's probably going to mature
over time and have more stable pricing
isn't it likely that that's actually a
better currency than gold as a private
currency uh question for Larry called
Larry yeah uh this reminds me uh gives
me a chance to plug my forthcoming book
which is coming out in April entitled
better money colon gold Fiat or Bitcoin
question mark and there I addressed this
question if you look at the supply curve
for Bitcoin it's vertical
and that means shifts in demand are
going to be fully reflected in the price
there's no response in the quantity
that's the big virtue that a gold
standard has over a Bitcoin standard and
so it seems to me that people would
gravitate toward a gold standard for
that reason now I might be wrong
uh if the public Embraces a Bitcoin
standard great but there's no built-in
tendency as Google sorry is bitcoin's
market cap grew you didn't see any
decrease in the volatility of its
purchasing power and as its market cap
fell
you didn't see an increase so there's no
correlation between those two things so
would you say for a flexible crypto uh
you could make not Bitcoin but a crypto
flexible what do you mean what do you
mean by there are projects underway and
in fact I'm Consulting with one of them
oh wow making money from that to provide
yes
to provide a cryptocurrency with a more
elastic Supply oh wow okay but of course
it all has to be formulaic there's no
discretion here so we have to write down
a formula for how the money supply
should respond to changes in the
purchasing power can be called the
Larry's nice uh so we're actually in
agreement the project is
a correction agreement here I think the
issue is uh that that crypto has
incredible volatility
uh and and there are all sorts of some
security issues too about uh crypto as
well uh so uh you know I I have a box in
my textbook said is is Bitcoin money and
the answer is money has three
characteristics that are extremely uh
that Define what we mean by money one
has to be unit of account
okay it has to be a a unit of account it
has to be a transaction medium and a
store of value now crypto actually may
be a better transaction medium because
of this blockchain technology that you
you don't have to wait to get the money
it's it's instantaneous so it so
blockchain technology has some real
pluses to it uh but the other hand it
just has this incredible volatility
which means it's not a good unit of
account because I mean prices will be
bopping around like crazy every day you
think about going to the supermarket and
you know you may not have a a inflation
rate over the hundred years but every
day there's a 10 difference in the price
of oranges you get to be pretty crazy in
that kind of world and as a result of
its being very volatile much more
volatile than other assets like stocks
and bonds it's actually uh has problems
as a store of value so I I think that
that some of the technology from crypto
is going to be very valuable uh and
that's going to be the transaction
medium part of it but I do think that as
it's designed now it's it's not a viable
option yeah thanks we have a question
from the balcony so please State your
question in the balcony go ahead take it
away
is it no you need the mic go ahead yes
yes so I agree with Professor Fred that
we do need a lender of Last Resort but
we didn't talk tonight about the
politics of the fed and I don't think
it's a coincidence that they kept the
easy money policy up until Powell got
re-nominated and only then started
tightening because Powell wanted to get
renominated and he knew in order to do
that he had to placate the Democrats and
their party line was we have to keep
throwing money in and then he had to
placate uh Maxine Waters that yes the
fed's job is to create diversity equity
and inclusion and to fight climate
change blah blah blah and only after
that entire process then get down to the
business of starting of raising rates
isn't the FED uh isn't the FED two ruled
by politics I think is the question yeah
so so look I've spent a lot of time at
the Federal Reserve as I said I spent
three years uh in the 1990s being
sitting in the back of the room in the
fomc meetings I spent another two years
whereas at the table uh I've been uh
involved in terms of the Federal Reserve
Bank of New York where I was involved
with the research Department
and I I can tell you that I never ever
felt that politics was what was driving
monetary policy concerns and I I'll tell
you that that uh uh there's a small P
politics where it is Jay Powell is
actually brilliant
uh at uh getting the uh Congress people
understand that that uh attacking the
Fed was not a great thing to do and
particularly putting crazies on the
Federal Reserve board was not a great
thing to do because Donald Trump has you
know the the Republican party and a lot
of people are enthralled by Donald Trump
and will will support uh his views that
the election was fraudulent on the other
hand those same Republicans weren't
willing to actually put in the crazy
people that he wanted to put in as
governors
so in in that sense the FED could be
political I think that Jay did a very
good job in that regard but people
always say this oh the FED is doing this
because of politics but if you actually
look at this and look at the history of
of of of the FED certainly in the last
20 years or so there's absolutely no
evidence that that's true
so as I say there are issues and
regulation that I do worry about a
little bit on that and in fact I have
not been happy with the fact that the
FED has talked about uh climate change
and so forth uh or inequality is issues
for the central bank to be involved in
because it absolutely should not be
involved in those issues even if you
think they're very important to solve so
you know I do think that climate change
is a big issue but it's not something a
central bank should deal with it's a
question of of what governments should
do deal with and whether they'll deal
with it an appropriate way which again
is a real problem because even if this
is Extreme externality which there is
the governments don't always do the
right thing so it's complicated
uh coming from you on that question
Larry no comment okay
um uh a question yeah hi uh so I'm I was
trying to figure out how to turn this
into a question and I'll do my best I
apologize if it's a little foggy but
um one of the things that I've uh one of
several things that I'm trying to deal
with is you know the whole question of
gold and what's so special about that
you just said uh Larry what's special
there's nothing necessarily special
about gold
um in my opinion I think that money is
basically a you know a way to get your
stuff your goods and services and money
and gold is a pretty poor approximation
of the global economy the only thing is
it's it's hard to find Etc and so what
I'm trying to find in this debate is
what is the alternative I'm not sure
with gold you have Alchemy you have
people who are trying to create gold out
of thin air if they were successful in
that it would destroy gold as well so it
just happened and we've never figured
that out in a efficient manner so what
is the alternative
um because I don't think it's gold
necessarily it's been tried many times
um I'm not you know Bitcoin and crypto
it's still early phases maybe an elastic
crypto maybe that could work because
then it can Flex with the economy with
global growth and Global Supply of goods
and services but I have yet to actually
hear like a solid explanation of what
would replace it perhaps talk more about
your last of crypto Larry but take the
question in any case
yeah so the the great virtue of the gold
standard was one that it was apolitical
right the quantity of money did not
depend on a committee meeting and
deciding based on their reading of the
economic numbers what it should be
uh and it responded in a way that
stabilized its purchasing power
and which has great benefits even if
it's not you know from day to day
it's nice to have 30-year bonds 50-year
bonds even 100 Year Bonds were issued
under the gold standard nobody issues
them under a Fiat standard
there's just too much unpredictability
and
there is more smoothness in the
inflation rate from year to year under a
Fiat standard
but there's less predictability of the
price level because there's no mean
reversion
whereas in a gold standard if you see
the price level falling for uh you can
be pretty sure that it's coming back up
and if you see it Rising you can be
pretty sure it's coming back down
uh sooner or later
and Fiat standards don't have that
property that's more of a random walk if
you go out five ten twenty years that is
in the paper I mentioned that I did with
celgid and the straps the straps ran
these forecasts if you knew what you
knew up until the day you were making
the forecast of what the price level was
going to be 10 years out how wrong would
you be
you're a lot longer under Fiat standards
than you were under the gold standard
and at 30 years the difference is really
big
not under a shorter Horizon I think
that's really part of the debate even as
like five years oh that's a long time
okay
um next question
all right this question is primarily for
Larry but it can definitely be for both
of you I'm curious to hear what both of
you have to say uh Larry I agreed with
90 of what you said so of course I have
to focus on the other 10 uh
I tend to be skeptical of the FED in all
situations except for probably World War
II where the United States came out of
World War II so decisively uh in part
because the Fed was so aggressive with
war bonds interest rates and things like
that uh so prosperous as a matter of
fact that not only were we better after
the fact than we were before arguably
but we could also defibrillate Japan's
economy as well at the same time I don't
see how free Banks could do better in
that scenario so I'm curious to hear if
you think they would or if World War II
is an exceptional circumstance where the
FED would be uniquely suited to do well
yeah what's your thoughts on this
good well to fight Wars governments need
to borrow money they can borrow money
from a competitive banking system as
well as from a central bank
I mean that's the short answer so
the Fed was actually very passive during
the second world war they bought all the
bonds the treasury wanted to sell them
in fact they pegged the yield on
Treasury bonds
I haven't really thought about the
counterfactual of what if there wasn't a
central bank and there was a competitive
market for treasury bonds but I don't
have any reason to think that it would
have been some kind of disaster but and
I want to agree that that monetary
policy was not what helped us win World
War II the FED basically stopped doing
monetary policy in fact it paid interest
rates effectively at zero uh for a very
long-term period of time and then of
course that actually led to a problem
where after the war was over where there
was going to be inflation and it then
had to be a fight between Treasury and
the fed and something called the FED
treasury Accord in March of 1951 is a
very important event in monetary history
so uh I don't think that's the problem I
don't in this case don't give too much
credit to the FED okay sounds good yeah
uh a question in the balcony take it
away hi uh yeah this question is more
for Mr White uh also I initially voted
undecided so not trying to go after you
here but the question is
um how would the gold standard system be
able to address the large economic
shocks that Mr Michigan referred to uh
or historically maybe what were some
examples where they were able to address
them in the past
well uh
the central sorry the the Clearinghouse
associations were able to address
extraordinary liquidity needs
uh
normally Clearinghouse associations ran
on 100 Reserve basis
but if there was a kind of common shock
where all the bank's customers were
demanding more currency
they could issue more currency as long
as people were going to hold the
banknotes and not redeem them then
everything was fine
if people were demanding gold then the
Clearinghouse Association had to get
involved and they would stretch the
existing reserves by lending new
reserves into existence so they switched
from 100 Reserve institution to a
fractional Reserve Institution
and then when the crisis was over the
banks that had borrowed reserves had to
pay them back and the system worked
pretty well
there was only one case ever that my
former colleague Richard Timberlake has
studied this so look up his work if you
want to read more about it
now in terms of other kinds of
shocks like pandemics
those are not really problems for
monetary policy those are real shocks to
the economy so they're going to have a
negative impact regardless of the course
of monetary policy you can't wish them
away by printing money if there's a big
shock to the supply of labor let's say
so the as I said before the period of
the classical gold standard was one of
pretty moderate variation in real output
and the U.S was didn't have a good
banking system at the time so it's
actually kind of surprising how moderate
the variations in real output work as we
did have those financial panics other
countries of by having less restricted
banking systems like Canada had milder
uh and
milder recessions and less variability
of output than even the U.S
so that's how I would answer the
question there wasn't
any kind of uh sort of global crisis
until of course World War one and World
War one they suspended the gold standard
so you can't really say well gold
standard failed to handle or failed to
finance World War One it wasn't tried
and found one thing it wasn't tried it
was eliminated so here we really do
disagree uh it's true for small shocks
it's not a big deal but when shocks are
big enough
uh then in fact in fact the the uh 1873
is 1873 I think so 7379 was a very
serious uh question the 1907 episode
that's when you really need a lender of
Last Resort that's when the
Clearinghouse Clearinghouse in effect
get overwhelmed they just can't produce
enough liquidity they're actually good
at producing liquidity for small shocks
and we agree on on that the second issue
I think that I really strongly strongly
disagree with you on which is I think a
lack of understanding of what happens in
financial crises which is yes it's true
that covid was a real shock and if
that's all that happened it wouldn't
have been a very big deal
the problem was the spillovers to the
financial system if you look at what
happened with covet first started to
happen this system was seizing up again
and in fact the shock was actually I
think worse in many ways than the shocks
the the housing shock that caused the
global financial crisis so it's exactly
this issue that when real shock then
gets into this financial system destroys
the financial system and in fact what
happens then is that you no longer have
the capability of moving funds from
people with excess funds to people with
good profit opportunities that's death
and that's what happened the Great
Depression that's what could have
happened to GSC and also very much could
have happened during the coveted
pandemic and thank God we had somebody
around who could prevent that from
happening
um I'm afraid we've exhausted the time
for the questions uh I want to again say
that there is an after party both of our
Debaters have consented to come to the
party you'll see they are both very
approachable so you can ask your
question of them then but do we now have
to go to the summation portion of the
evening and Larry white you're up for
five minutes to give your summation
thank you
so I'm not sure what I can add to what
I've already said
um
what we rely on a monetary system to do
is to
allow us to gather savings uh sorry a
banking system gather savings
intermediate into Lending and we want a
system in which
the banks are robust uh to monetary
shocks and to real shocks
and a system where there's free
competition and no uh lender of Last
Resort is one where banks are going to
have to operate on their own
resources
or resources they can convince other
Banks to provide to them and to do that
they have to actually be solvent uh
and so the the usual complaint about
banking under a system without a central
bank without a lender of last resort was
that Bankers were too conservative
they wouldn't lend you money unless you
didn't need it if unless you could prove
that you didn't need it
uh
that's an exaggeration of course but we
do want Banks to be prudent
we don't want Banks to feel that okay if
I make this mistake but all the other
Banks make it too then I'm going to be
bailed out
uh
so a system uh based on competition and
I I keep reiterating uh the evidence we
have from the period before the first
world war is that this worked quite well
if we just look at the United States it
worked even better if we look at systems
that were less
restricted in what the banks could do is
quite robust
does uh Finance real economic growth and
does so in a non-inflationary way
so by switching to a system run by the
Federal Reserve we've gotten higher
inflation
we haven't gotten any greater Financial
stability we've gotten a more fragile
Financial system uh from the evidence
we've seen recently
and so somehow we have to turn that ship
around
and introduce more competition and more
fear of failure uh into the financial
system
and that way we can have uh I think the
best combination
of
freedom and Innovation uh responsibility
and Innovation maybe I should say
so I'm not promising a world in which
banks don't fail but one in which
failures are not contagious
banks will have
kept themselves separate from uh getting
involved in
the problems of other Banks
uh and so the system is decentralized
and the failure of any one institution
is not a big deal whereas when the FED
makes a mistake nowadays it's a doozy
and it carries along the entire
monetary and financial system with it
so let's not put all our eggs in that
basket let's decentralize let's
introduce more competition let's
introduce more responsibility uh into
the financial system let's ReDiscover
sound banking
thank you
five minutes five minutes of summation
take it away from Frederick so we agree
that actually that A lender blast Resort
does create moral hazard uh that uh uh
and and and
that by not having you might have less
moral hazard and as a result Banks would
be more prudent and that is something
that actually is is is a problem for a
lender of Last Resort operation
on the other hand we know that there are
shocks and particularly because it's
asymmetric information if you think
about what a paddock is all about is
that there's a shock one guy gets into
it may or may not be in trouble people
can't see through their balance sheets
particular Banks they worry whether it's
going to be a whole or not as a result
they have to take their money out in
fact there's an externality that if they
get there first they get their money out
first in fact this is why we call it a
run on the bank and then when One Bank
goes under that contagion can spread to
others and so again I recommend Friedman
Schwartz discussion of what went on
about the so-called contagion of fear uh
and explaining how the First Banking
crisis in 1930 of the Great Depression
actually led to situation getting much
worse the way I think about this is that
we can actually eliminate moral hazard
let's think about driving so you can
drive and you can say you know what this
that if we put in seat belts and you
have to wear seat belts and we put in
airbags you'll Drive will you'll drive
less safely because the the probability
of getting killed in an accident goes
down a lot in fact the solution to the
problem is let's put some some knives
into the steering wheel
and you're going to drive really safely
then
I still would say that the likelihood of
having bad outcomes would be much higher
in that kind of situation so I think
that's the way I uh uh I really think
about this and and to summarize I think
the issue here really is about the
overall economy's economic performance
and both in terms of the issue of of
shocks that are very big shocks that are
real shocks nothing to do with the fed
or anything else that that they can
propagate through the financial system
uh which is critical to the success of
an economy banking Capital moved from
from people who have excess Capital to
people with productive investment
opportunities that's why countries get
get rich that's what capitalism is all
about uh when you think about uh it's
being successful and but there are times
when information flows stop that's what
a financial crisis basically is and you
no longer can get that to happen then
you're in deep trouble and in fact
having a lender of Last Resort is
absolutely critical it's why the Fed was
actually initially uh created it's
actually the Bank of Canada was one of
the latest to have a central bank they
didn't come into the 1930s
that's a key issue in terms of economic
performance and I would also argue we
could also get this whole debate about
rules versus discretion which I don't
want to get into here but it's related
to this that uh that basically having
this hard and fast Peg to uh a commodity
let's say like gold or something else is
something that actually will produce uh
what's the really the price level over
very long Horizons but that's not what's
really relevant to business decisions
and household decisions so Alan
Greenspan had this wonderful definition
of price stability and it's very
behavioral and actually it's a very
similar definition to the Supreme
Court's definition of pornography so
what was the Supreme Court's definition
of pornography you know when you see it
and that's what Greenspan said about
price stability he said when uh you're
doing your job properly with price
stability then in terms of your business
and household decisions you're not
spending a lot of time worrying about
what's going to happen to uh the future
price level
and that produces an economy that's
efficient that works very well
uh and so and that's actually not a
long-term thing that's actually asking
what's going to happen you know when I
go to the store three months from now
maybe a year from now but certainly not
you know 10 years 30 years or whatever I
you know that issue is not what's really
relevant to household's decisions so
thinking about the green definition also
tells you why I think that that uh the
gold standard period is not one that
advocates for eliminating the FED in
fact the FED I think will produce better
economic performance both on the issues
of making sure that their shocks don't
blow us up and secondly that that we'll
have a situation where in fact it's more
predictable what price is going to be in
the short term and that's what's
relevant to people thank you very much
[Applause]
so Jane please open the voting yes no or
undecided replacing the Federal Reserve
with free market institutions would
significantly improve the economy's
money Banking and Financial systems I
have in my hand the soil form Tootsie
Roll which will go to the winner of this
voting uh while you were voting yep
that's the tootsie roll now yes yes
while you were voting I just want to
announce again that if you follow the
crowds two blocks Uptown to 55 great
Jones Street you can be at the after
party and again both Professor Michigan
and Professor white have consented to
come to the after party uh most of us
good half the audience knows where to go
so just follow them including Larry he
knows where to go in that case as well I
also want to announce that a new Venture
which is the soul forms Bastion Society
Salon Sunday afternoon at 2 p.m we will
be discussing this debate and Larry who
will be in town Larry white will be in
town he will come and be in the hot seat
about the debate at 12 30 an hour and a
half earlier I'm going to show the
debate on our large screen for those who
didn't make it to the debate or want to
refresh her then Larry will show up for
the best Society sell on again this
Sunday our next debate our next debate
will be on Tuesday February 21st a mises
Institute senior fellow Ryan mcmaken
will defend the resolution the breakup
of the United States into different
regions is a workable option likely to
bring a marked improvement in human
Affairs which of course has
complications for this evening's debate
and that will be against libertarian
party classical liberal caucus us chair
Jonathan Casey again that's Tuesday
February 21st our next debate on
Thursday March 30th there will be a
debate between senior Manhattan
Institute senior fellow Jason Riley who
will defend the resolution upward
Mobility for black Americans
lies in rejecting the policies
a progressive government while making
the most of the opportunities offered by
American society Jason Riley will take
the affirmative and NYU Professor Nicole
Singh will take the negative on that
debate and that will be Thursday March
30th also looking far ahead we are
taking our show on the road again as we
did for the last two years on June 19th
to the 25th we will be taking the soul
form to the porcupine Freedom Festival
in Lancaster New Hampshire that's June
19th to 25th on the Friday of that of
that week I will be debating David
Friedman the illustrious and widely
published son of Milton Friedman he will
defend the resolution the right way to
persuade people of libertarianism is by
showing them that it's outcomes are
superior without any resort to the
flawed no non-aggression principle again
taking the negative on that will be me
and let's see and how we're still coming
the vote is coming in yeah all right and
then also uh we have more to come but uh
I guess I'll announce that at some other
point because it looks as though the
Voting is coming in drumroll please uh
and uh no
thank you
yeah okay um yes well oh well okay uh we
uh
laughs yeah
um the the yes votes for the resolution
uh began at 41.9 percent uh and the post
vote for the resolution ended at 48.1
percent picked up 6.2 percentage points
that's the number that beat but no vote
went from 25.8 to 32.5 very very close
it picked up 6.9 percent points are you
lost by a few tenths of a point Larry
what uh yeah you you picked up a few
tenths of a point more than Larry that's
a few tenths of a point it's probably a
statistical error but
wrong
thank you thank you to folks Debaters 55
great Jones Street for the after party
see you then